me Robinson protests in the UK right now
see I don't know enough about that story
other than the fact that a bunch of
people are mad at me on Twitter I don't
even know what that is I'm gonna back
away and then I saw it was something
about he was he was filming outside of a
trial of muslim paedophiles yes there
are these grooming gangs yeah grooming
gang
yeah tell me the whole story so I don't
want to do this as if I'm the freakin
lawyer of the whole thing but in effect
he was filming outside of the the trial
for these this group of men that are
raping they're raping like 12 and 13
year old girls basically they're on
trial he had already been on probation
or something for something else and
you're not allowed to film outside a
court house so technically I suppose he
is in jail now for the right reasons but
there's a lot of people that think he's
not gonna survive being in jail and I
look I had the guy on my show have you
ever have you ever talked to him no I
didn't know anything about him until
this this thing happens yeah I mean he
has no I know it's a lot no I do have
kids
don't you have to occasionally just pick
one and you're like this one dude
there's a lot of them I just don't know
I don't know what's going on like people
how come you're not calmer than this
like I don't even know about it you [ __ ]
I know I love it I love that would you
sit out sending on Twitter for six hours
and people start screaming at you like
god that proves you or you say anything
about it yeah oh you talk all day long
this is not then this comes up and you
know your word like I don't even hear
about some just now yeah well alright
let's not dive too deep in that so quick
on Jones though so I'm not actually in
case you think I am I'm not giving you
[ __ ] for doing I'm not sure is I'm just
curious because I think part of the
article that that Barry Weiss wrote in
The Times about us she was talking about
that and there's a line in there where
she said you know if you talk to these
people meaning Jones and Serna vich and
all knew that you're either cynical or
stupid and in effect that was that was a
shot at me and you it wasn't a shot at
anybody else because they don't have to
talk to other people you know you mean
like I love Eric and Brett Weinstein you
know what she said there's you're yes we
can probably find the line but it was
that you'd have to I think it was you'd
have to be cynical or stupid I would
argue that I mean argue against that
because I don't think you have to be
either cynic or stupid you just have to
be a person talking to someone just
because you're talking to someone
doesn't mean you agree with them yeah
use the idea of giving someone a
platform like I'm gonna have Ted
Nugent on the podcast right you
obviously endorsed everything he's ever
since that's what you're saying right if
you have one that's that's the only way
that's it how come you can't just talk
to the guy and find out like like
Candice Owens I don't agree with
everything Candice Owen says yeah with a
lot of it yeah and this is nothing wrong
with having a conversation like that in
fact it's illuminating what do you got
here that's funny pulling up the line
this is from The Times piece okay it
says yes to me that if you're willing to
sit across from and Alex challenger Mike
Stern de vich and take him seriously
there's a high probability that you're
either cynical or stupid now if there's
a reason for shorting the IDW it's the
inability of certain members to see this
as a fatal error so now that's Rogan and
Reuben here's nothing that saying yeah I
get it I'm just definitely seeing things
you can criticize about me but I have
the list right but here's the thing if
you're saying I'm taking him seriously I
got Alex high and drunk and he started
talking about interdimensional child
molesters like if anything it showed
people who he really is like I've known
the guy forever I've partied with that
dude I've had him coming to my commie
shows and we've gotten [ __ ] up and ran
around the town and went to bars
together back before everybody knew who
he was - I could go places he's a fun
guy I don't believe everything he
believes I think he's silly in a lot of
ways but I like a lot of people that I
don't agree with I don't have to agree
with them I didn't know about his Sandy
Hook denial if I did it would have been
the first thing I pressed him on yeah
when I talked to him I wanted to do it
with my crazy friend Eddie Bravo because
he believes every [ __ ] conspiracy
theory yeah and I wanted to get him with
Alex together and it was the [ __ ]
that I hoped it would be it was but the
good thing about it is it showed people
who Alex really is it showed a side of
him that you just don't get from his
infowar show you get to see him hi and
laughing and drunk and pound and whiskey
and [ __ ] around and people like oh I
could see why you liked that guy and I
can see why he's fun we had a good time
together doesn't mean I endorse his
opinions on things and the idea that
this is only red or white that it is one
or zero it's binary
that's ridiculous yeah why it's
ridiculous I just didn't those two
choices of adjectives I just thought
were slightly like you could shake
her position I think I think she's doing
a smart thing because she's a writer for
the New York Times I do have a lot of
ridiculous people on and you have had
ridiculous people on to salutely so what
she's saying makes sense if you take
them seriously but she left that caveat
if you take I'm seriously I do not take
Alex Jones's opinion on interdimensional
child molester seriously I don't I don't
smoke pot once a year to test to see
what George Soros has done with the
marijuana right George Soros is giving
the marijuana of [ __ ] dosage
recommendations like that's pretty sure
Roseanne told me that too well she
thinks that's another thing I don't know
what to do with her now she thinks she
apologized stood up she said George
Soros was a Nazi or something yeah he
was captured by the Nazis I mean he was
like why anyway this piracies yeah this
gatekeeping thing I just think it's
interesting because if we're gonna do
what we do well at whatever level we do
it it's like we're gonna have to talk to
people that people don't like and listen
look Larry King this is the one thing I
always say it's like Larry King in the
in his heyday think of the prime Larry
King right so 1991 CNN prime time yeah
he could have you know the OJ Simpson
lawyers on Monday he could have the
Castro Seinfeld on Tuesday he could have
a magician on Wednesday he could have
Lucille Ball if she was still alive on
Thursday and then you know George the
Secretary of State or something so no
one thought he endorsed all of those
ideas or friends with all those people
but I think somehow now because because
this feels like your home mine is
actually in my home hmm
the way we are we're different we're
friendlier we're not sitting here with
no cards and with ifvs and it doesn't
feel well produced and planned and all
that even though I think we both do a
hell of a [ __ ] professional show that
I think we're both really proud of I
think because of that they think now
you're seeing the real them or so or
something like that like it's it's not
just looking for [ __ ] to complain about
listen one of the reasons why I decided
to a podcast in the first place because
I wanted to be able to do whatever I
wanted I wanted to be able to talk to my
friends have a good time [ __ ] around
along the line it became something
different and along the line I became
not just talking to my friends it became
talking to
people that are famous or interesting
people or professors or writers or
whoever it is mm-hmm
and I'm gonna do whatever the [ __ ] I
want yeah and that's why I'm doing this
I'm gonna do whatever the [ __ ] I want if
I want to talk to and if you don't like
who I'm talking to
it's super simple you just don't listen
to that episode and go oh drogon you're
all right now all you have is all right
people you think you're balanced out
because you have Abby Martin on once a
year I just think I talk to people you
know I talk to a lot of people there's I
like talking to people I like talking to
people I agree with and I occasionally
talk to people I disagree with how I get
something out of that too